i could not breathe
[Music]
guys welcome back to monday yeah yeah
monday fun day with your boys at sng you
know the vibes this is episode 198
198. um
i think it's 119 yeah i think it's about
19. if it's not it's not and whatever in
it but yeah we're pretty certain it's
119. um
and guys
welcome back we hope you're enjoying
what's been going on recently um
and
this is going to be the one of the last
times we can say it guys october 10th
thank you bro october same wavelength
great minds think alike october 10th
guys
bbe
podcast festival festival
bare manner rocking up
tickets are cha cha cha cha i don't know
if they're sold out i don't know if they
are if they're not
get on there links in the bio guys links
in the bio we're down in london on the
10th we're meeting and greeting we're
chin wagging with shits and gigging
we're doing what we do best
um are we headlining the ting again we
don't know it seems that way that's the
narrative that's been pushed out there
we're humbled to oblige but look we
don't want to [ __ ] on anyone else
we're just rocking up we happen to be
lost
um i'm just gonna do our thing we're
just gonna show up do our thing and um
and skidaddle um so guys if you wanna
come to the show and show some love have
some laughs and then
meet us afterwards
like i said link's in the description
um we'll be dope and we would love to
see you mum and i would love to see you
man um guys
again if you can't be asked to wait till
next monday to see the one after this
hop on over to patreon that's
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
uh we're running games over there like
picky poison that we can't do over here
youtube said we need to find another
outlet spotify said we need to find out
outlet just to let the world know what's
really going on behind the scenes um so
yeah that's what patreon does for us
uncensored uncut
um raw on the field raw unfiltered
anything goes uh we've got a great
community if you want prep if you want
to send in the [ __ ] and and and have
answers questions and you can't be asked
to wait three months because we've got
got such a backlog heading over to
patreon and you get first dibs so
threshold treatment yeah special
treatment over there guys and it's just
three pound a month 10p a day run the p
basic and uh guys without further ado i
believe we've got foo head and his for
fuzz and these fun facts so remember i
did um a fun fact about teddy roosevelt
about how
um the teddy bear yeah he was teddy bear
was named after him so there's another
fun fact about him so in 1912 26 u.s
president theodore roosevelt was shot in
the chest prior to giving a speech
noticing that the bullet missed his
lungs he carried on with blood seep from
his shirt he delivered a full 90 minute
speech before accepting medical
attention
in
1912
i believe that's cap
i'm 100 saying that's cap
that seems like propaganda that he spun
himself yeah no one was at this chat no
one knows but back back then there was
no social media there's no pictures
there was nothing so no one could verify
whether it happened or not 90 minutes i
think that's
a bullet in your chest doesn't say maybe
if you got shot and you like you said uh
you spoke about for five ten seconds
longer before you
dropped off but i gave a 90-minute
speech he just happened to notice it
didn't hit his lung
do you think i'm noticing something like
that i'll be on the floor screaming if i
see any form of blood dripping down my
teeth oh [ __ ] down the floor
i'm done i'll collapse i'm on the floor
yeah that's cat exit wound and all i'm
on the floor yeah 100 that's cap that's
cap yeah i need someone that can verify
this that's [ __ ] i'm certain that's
[ __ ] 90 minutes an hour and a half
of blood gushing out football that's a
that's a that's a full football game
it's impossible
with a foreign body just embedded in
your skin
this cap even though it's called a fun
fact this cap and what happened what
donny just shot him security took him
out and he's like [ __ ] and then just
carry it nah
nah
your your agents need to get you out of
there
i don't think daddy had agents back in
1912 yeah true yeah that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm certain of it but if it's
not then fair play man that's that's a
different type of that's gangster
there's definitely gangster that's
that's right or die i would never do
that oh god i'm president and i just got
shot
take me to the hospital now my country
needs to treat me now more than ever
treat me i'll hand him my resignation
the next day clearly you man don't want
me
if you don't want me just [ __ ] say so
just laughter don't shoot me just
impeach me fam do it the legal way yeah
you know don't try and done my dance
like that yeah yeah yeah it's not fair
yeah you didn't need to shoot me but i
don't need to be dead for this you know
that being said i was listening to a
part the other day to speak about this
and i actually agree
like
what kind of sociopath do you think it
takes for someone to want to be like
president or want to be like prime
minister bro i oh i would never want to
run a country or a state or something
like that that's that's just not in my
range
yeah that would scare me stuff like that
was too much pressure for me fam or
what kind of person like
do you rock up to and be like oh do you
want to be prime minister
everyone would say no of course everyone
10 out of 10 people say of course
why would i want that job on me
people were like
from young will like wake up they want
to they get an education they get a
degree they go all these channels to
become an mp to all these things so i i
want to run the labour party i want to
be prime minister all these things
i want to run the country especially if
like especially if you're american like
you'd be or i'd say british where you'd
have to be in some sort of form of
service like worked in an army or done
something some type of like marine or
something something something so they're
literally strategically working their
way up to be an mp or be your president
or be a prime minister or something like
that it's like oh god no
yeah like you're
you're sociopath that's just nah man
you're a sociopath
how can you want that who wants that who
wakes up and thinks i feel like this i
want to be the boss of all bosses that's
just too much for me man that's too much
for me
i couldn't sleep at night i wouldn't be
able to
this imagine being like demand that were
all in power during like the initial
coverage strike
the sheer panic fam everyone's looking
to you fam everyone send in for boris
everyone
put this many billion into this [ __ ]
track and trace app that don't even work
it's like it wasn't me
did i develop the app no
man sent me his qualifications
he said i could patent i gave him the
job i said make that
how much do you need
59 billion
steep but it's gonna happen
i'm not an app developer i don't [ __ ]
know how much these things cost
yeah use it have it there you go is it
gonna make the nation better i bet it
sounds like it yeah
i ain't got a plan b fam you sold me on
it here you go make the thing and now
everyone send it for my job because it
didn't work out
what do you want from me
i'm doing my best no [ __ ] i'm doing
my best yeah yeah like and the thing is
what you realize like if you go back in
the ages
everyone always hates the leader of
course not everyone but like there is a
time there will be a time where you'd
hate the leader
every time there's a leader there's a
great percentage of people that [ __ ]
hate your guts of course and it's like
what we gonna do you can't please
everyone because everyone didn't vote
for that person yeah exactly can't
please have more but it's weird on how
like obviously living in like a
democracy where people get voted into
power and stuff
it's like it's crazy how like human
nature like
when people don't get their way
it's like we're all children really so
like for example like when you take kids
um and you're like cool
this kid like for example if me and
brother were like when we were little or
whatever and oh i want to go swimming
today mm-hmm and i wouldn't do this
today oh i'm going to go bowling today
so let's just say your dad's like all
right cool
flip a coin
if his heads were going swimming if his
tails we're going bowling we're going
bowling yeah is that fair yes is that
fair yes flip the coin
tails we're going bowling
vex
this is [ __ ] this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah batman you agreed to the
terms yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah now i'm
livid this is not on i'm not going
bowling i'll tell you now i'm not going
back for free i'm doing it i'm sick of
going [ __ ] bowling this is [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah man and
same thing when we were kids actually i
think i might have said this before but
my dad used to take us to blockbusters
every saturday yes you did and i would
always get um a different movie every
week
he would always get the never-ending
[ __ ] story the never-ending story
every single week and the rules were we
both had to watch each other's movie bro
he would always watch mine and i would
always watch his fam i'm happy as larry
watch your mind
happy as larry
gang if he walked out because he don't
want to watch it i'm writing him out to
my dad get your ass back in here and
watch this
get in here and watch this do you know
the rules you have to watch it
fam
as soon as the never ending story turns
on
um
yeah turn this [ __ ] off do you not did
you not ever watch his one first
considering you watch the same movie
probably i can't remember but yeah
i just hate the whole concept it's the
same with like democracy now is like
we know the rules you go in you vote for
who you want
you hope everyone agrees with you and
they get the votes
the person that you didn't want to get
voted in gets voted in
everyone's face especially with like the
trump stuff
because that caused like a massive issue
and people say that's not my president
that's not my president yeah it is
though yeah
i don't know what you want to say
if not then move to north korea don't
invoke anyone
they can't
oh
yeah
um
yeah either that will work or go to a
country that has a [ __ ] emperor go to
transit that has a king
that no one gets voted in
an emperor wow that's that's back a day
china
you know japan still has an emperor do
they i only realized it watching the
olympics every week really i only knew
when they did the opening ceremony and
they were like cool and here comes the
emperor and he's sitting next to like
the
president of the olympic committee or
whatever
and i'm like
emperor
these men still have an emperor so
that's the official leader the emperor
of japan i'm actually not sure i don't
know if i don't know if it's a situation
where like how we have the queen
and we still have a prime minister i'm
still have a promise i'm not sure if
it's like that let me google it because
i'm sure um
i'm sure it is like that because
the
i'm sure japan is a democratic
society
um
yeah emperor of japan
naruhito
okay
um
yeah they classified his majesty and
blah blah blah yeah
okay he's that guy
cool but yeah i don't know what kind of
political power he has he might have all
the power he might have none i really
have no idea
um that's news to me like about that bro
when i saw it i was like what and the
thing is as well it actually makes me
it makes me realize
oh wow i'm living as a hypocrite because
like as soon as i saw that i was
thinking how have you man still got an
emperor like what the [ __ ] is that we've
been had a queen
yeah yeah yeah and it's just normal this
is normal it's like the exact same thing
yeah but as soon as i saw emperor i was
like i'm seeing so outdated yeah like
you might need to get get with it get
him out what's that these times
lizzy's just
chilling
okay guys
it's that time again
you know the vibes is trying to shed
some love on the homies
the uh the godfathers of grooming
grooming yeah um
yeah man the
the pubescent pube shavers
um anyway yeah guys
quick shout out to today's sponsor which
is of course the one and only manscaped
you already know what you need to do you
already know what you need to type we're
just going to reiterate and uh
and just remind
that guy's
like ladies love cool james
ll cool j he knew the vibes from early
you got artists out here like babyface
fam
smooth criminal
like these are all underwritten signs
that no one's paying attention to
get your [ __ ] chopped down i remember
when i was a young man
a teenage man and i've seen a girl we
got down to the nitty-gritty and she
said afterwards i ah
have you ever thought about you know a
cheeky
i was gobsmacked
i was mortified that night i went
straight in the bathroom
and it was a mess
there was knick-knack paddy gonna say
clippers yeah clippers and scissors bro
with scissors has just fam edward says
how the thing was flying out i did a
hack job i did a hack job i couldn't get
into the the grips the crevices yeah
yeah i had to
steal my dad's head razor oh my goodness
i didn't like him anyway so
i would shave my balls with his clippers
i just put it back
yeah but bro i nicked it bro i was
bleeding weekly for this and it wasn't
worth it and now we're here guys you
don't have to go through that you can
pick yourself up the performance package
4.0 at manscape.com
right now use the code sng tell them we
sent you um and you'll get yourself
twenty percent off and free shipping so
that's massage.com
code is sng
sierra november golf
um
20 off free shipping worldwide we're
going to go back to the episode now
thank you for listening
been chilling on the phone
i told you i've been watching uh
google box like the old ones on netflix
binging them and they were doing um they
were talking about
what was they talking about they were
talking about like um prince um
oh what's his name the pedo one andrew
andrew
and you think
ra like
because i didn't even know who he was
before all this whole thing this epstein
thing kicked off i don't even know it
wasn't prince andrew neither did i i
didn't even know he was there they took
him out the media yeah yeah they took
him out to me existed
but then i i googled once i was watching
the goggleboss thing i was thinking who
is this bro actually
so we googled it and he's like the third
son
because he's prince charles's brother
so he's like the third song there's
prince charles there's another don i
don't know who it is and um there's
charles andrew and
i can't remember
at the time i remembered yeah yeah
so yeah i did research and then you
realize like ah
so he's just
the royal with [ __ ] all to do yeah
no wonder these is out here doing
[ __ ] no wonder he's making bedrooms
with american billionaires who have
islands of underage girls to [ __ ]
he's bored so bored bro but how do you
even
because obviously he
he would not have been shoned prior to
this so how do you even get yourself in
that stage you know
because obviously he's no we didn't know
about him or not necessarily we as a
nation but me and you didn't know about
him up until we watched um either
gogglebox or watch the epstein show um
to realize who prince andrew was um
but prior to this prior to the epstein
situation and him like i'm [ __ ]
underage women he would have been part
and parcel of the
the monarch or the monarchy
but how do you how do you get yourself
in a position where okay i'm gonna start
doing this i.e [ __ ] wrong with
younger girls when you know the power
kind of position of power you're in you
know like you're gonna get baited out
you're gonna get found out true but if
you think about it like the circles that
he's running with like it's not like he
was
in some
shady triad run sex trafficking ring
he's rolling with a billionaire
and like epstein's chilling with like
bill clinton
and like other like really really high
priority big deal people like world
leaders
so if this is the inner circle of the
world leaders and the the richest people
in the world he's probably figured that
i'm never gonna yeah he's thinking this
is patterned no one's caught no one no
one's gonna clock me yeah because if i'm
going down everyone's going down the
world's gonna blow up yeah yeah yeah so
if this gets found out there's something
for everyone so i might as well roll
with the punches but if it was some back
editing then yeah i don't think he would
i don't think he would have run with it
some shanking in the back alley yeah i
don't think it would have run that way
if it was some some shady
um
shady trafficking ring but yeah
billionaires presidents bro because
obviously have you seen the whole
epstein thing
you know what i think i told you before
i watched it up until
i realized these girls were just doing
this as their nine to five
and then i locked it off
like what'd you mean you went back
yeah yeah
yeah
once i realized
once they kept calling them survivors
instead of victims or whatever once it
said like sarah parsons survivor
and then
you'd uh and then you should be like oh
that's horrible she does so horrible
horrible yeah he made me do this and do
that it was disgusting and horrible and
i'm like that's dread and she said yeah
and then this went on for like three
years
and you're like three [ __ ] years
every monday wednesday friday for three
years this went on geez you're not a
survivor big man this was your job
this was your job gelane would pick you
up from your yard
guillain would pick you up from your
yard three times a week you would go
there get paid and go home like this was
your job
so as soon as i realized that it was
like episode two or three as soon as i
thought that i'd i'd turn the thing off
as i can't be bothered for this [ __ ]
she's got her own um
she's got her own uh documentary as or
glenn maxwell's on either sky atlantic
or sky dot heavenly i've recorded i've
not seen it yet though but it's like
how she came in contact with epstein and
like how she patted these women and blah
blah blah so it's all tied into the
epstein and epstein's saga so i do need
to watch it i do want to watch it rather
just to get more context because
i think i don't know if she actually got
caught apprehended or anything
i can't remember she's in pen right now
is she invented right now she's in pen
right now okay i couldn't remember yeah
yeah but yeah
it was intriguing purely because
obviously it came out after the absent
thing so i'm intrigued to watch it that
whole thing is mad the whole thing is
malarkey bro the whole thing i know yeah
why i was um leading towards what i was
leaning towards rather obviously you
were talking about the inner circle of
the higher powered people and blah blah
blah the president's whatever um
i don't know if you got up to that
episode but when epstein got caught or
where mc got um charged and everything
obviously he's pregnant with or he was
president with trump um so i don't know
if you saw that bit but as soon as
he got out it they interviewed trump
like blah blah like this is meant to be
your boy like you've seen pictures of
you blah blah and trump trump just outed
him saying
yeah he was my friend but i knew he was
capable of this [ __ ] he was like he sold
him out bro on the spot of course on the
small he was capable of looking there he
said something stupid along those lines
i'm not surprised and he was capable of
this
send him to jail stuff like that he fam
trump has no loyalty to anyone disown
him like that hundred percent trump's
been in this game yeah trump's been in
this game
his dad was rich he grew up rich and
he's rich and powerful he don't play
them kind of thing there yeah yeah oh
you were you you've been associated with
this like pedophile
i don't know that don he's a a menace to
society the only times i was hanging
around with him to stop him doing
something and he had the fbi in his
pocket so i couldn't say anything
but the whole reason i was ever with him
was to protect everyone
that's the whole reason now it's out in
the open send him yeah now it's all out
lock him up throw away the key
leave a rope in his room let him take
care of it
fam
yeah trump does not play doesn't play
that's jokes when i saw it i was like
[ __ ] out trump's the funniest
character of all time
just the funniest character oh you're
such a little boy fam there was one time
such a little boy fan there was one time
apparently he was having like a debate
okay uh on tv with uh some governor or
something i can't remember who the
debate was with i thought you're gonna
say something else but continue and um
as he's having this debate the um
he's on camera and then uh he's talking
about i can't remember how he said it
but he basically just like the guy's
short in it okay the guy who's debating
with his shot okay
and then he goes um
ah like while they're going through the
questions man's trump's not even
answering the question and he's like
i just don't think it's fair
that he should get a box to stand on and
i don't get a box everyone's are you
talking about and he's like
big man like
he's out here asking before we all the
cameras are on everything he's asking
for a box
if you're short you're sure so if he
gets a box i want a box
what fam and the thing is it's so west
on live tv on live tv if he gets a box i
want a box
if he if you're short just just be sure
it's fine
fam what this don did not mention no box
he didn't want nothing he's just sure
but he's basically but trump's obviously
trying to manipulate the thing
and
make out like this guy's insecure about
his height okay no one's talking about
his height okay but he's obviously
trump's obviously clocked that he's
short yeah that's a power play and he's
like big man just be short
it's like me just right now being like
big man just be short if you're short
you're short
you'll be like what are you doing what
the [ __ ] what are you doing
it's fine
you're not 511 like me
it's fine and donnie didn't ask for a
box no
man concocted the whole thing concocted
the whole thing
just as that's some power play like this
is not the guy you want he's insecure
about his height wow
he's not asking for boxes to stand on if
he gets a box i want to blow on him
and then they just moved on he's a youth
fan he's such a child he's a youth but
it's one of them ones that are like did
he ask for a box
but the guy he's crazy
he's crazy but he's too funny he did you
know he um
he uh
was like calling a fight the other day
no they hadn't uh like commented on a
fight
and there was a like a exhibition boxing
match between anderson silva
and tito ortiz okay so both like x mma
fighters they had a boxing match and
[ __ ] oh no
yeah it was amazing silver and then um
yeah they had trump and his son
commentate the fight why
this is recently
like two weeks ago what the [ __ ] yeah
mad it doesn't make no sense no sense
that makes no sense it makes no sense at
all
maybe i'm assuming they did obviously
they did it for publicity you get more
people to watch the show yeah who
wouldn't that's the thing as well
because he's such like a weirdo yeah who
wouldn't watch that but i've never heard
of it you just said it now but that's
still [ __ ] weird man bro super weird
super weird
um
right let's play a little game just for
fun
this is a basic one we played this those
times i know you get shook on the
pressure under pressure on the spot but
just try your best just let let it flow
let it flow and don't get stressed it's
an affiliate all over it we've got all
the time in the world
right just do a word association game
[Music]
so i say a word and you say a word that
has to relate to that word
yeah
okay you know word association yeah yeah
yeah all right cool so let's start off
with
oh actually no you can start no i start
gee i can't think
i need to i need to rebuttal off what
you say i can't think all right cool
door
handle
hold
hold
hold
hold um pull
yank
push
hard
soft
push hard
yeah hard push hard okay okay hard soft
um
supple
succulent
juicy
wet wet
mouth
stop whispering it that's it mouth
[Laughter]
all right next one
um
hair
head
suck
tongue
[Laughter]
hey man
right come on focus bro i am focused i'm
focused you don't want to be you're
still trying to chirps me brother focus
play the game i'm playing father play
better than i've ever done all right you
are you are you are okay um
wood
tree
branch twig
snap
crackle
pop
rice krispies cereal corn flakes
milk
sugar
cream
tea
warm coffee
warm cup yeah
um
beans
baked
cake
dessert
if you had
[Laughter]
i wish you could have caught my face in
slow motion what
sorry sorry the thing is
at first i genuinely thought you were
calling me like yeah yeah
i realized i mean like rid mid head spin
that you were actually calling me a
snack
ah okay one more round one more round
that's hilarious stop chasing me
um
right
laptop
keys
keyboard
piano
music
genre
films
series
binge
netflix
red
table
legs
chair
posture
back
shot
tequila
sip sip
bar
waiter
serve oh same thing
um
ah
i was gonna say you said wait i said
server i was like [ __ ] is the same thing
i lost it i was on a roll um [ __ ]
cool miner that was fun that was fun it
woke my brain up good
right i've got um
the other
what makes women ick
because i think oh yeah i think we did
the med one we did the men's men one i
think on the patreon yeah yeah
the women's
jesus
but a woman's version of
what gives women the egg
so
oh someone just put men in just men
shitbirds
long fingernails especially the pinky
bro what is that my barber has it mine
my barber has it my bob has it as well
my barber has when he's trimming me he's
always like family he does this to me
all the time
i [ __ ] hate it i want to get that
nasty thing off me my barber why do they
have that i don't know that's so weird
that you said your baba has it my bubba
[ __ ] where's your barber from country
oh um
[Music]
yeah he's from
i want to say
he
is from
oh
what uh zanzibar oh wow okay i think
you've told me before wow yeah
mine's from i think eritrea oh he's east
african for sure
but yeah i don't i fam always i think
two of them have it yeah the both
barbers that i go to you know the two
bubbles i'll go to i think i think you
remember them i don't know both of them
have the longest what the [ __ ] is that
no these men are snot and coke on their
breaks that's what it is
jesus christ
um
leg crossing of any description
that's
that's tough
nah nah this is this one oh jesus
that's cool that's normal if you'll if
you're relaxed with it just like that
that's that's calm yeah yeah the i can't
even do
um
men who love cats more than dogs
yeah
this one i don't understand cause i've
never i can't even comprehend it
men who lie on their belly in the bath
i can't even comprehend who which human
does that male or female cheeks just
rubbing above the water
to be fair yeah i know girls do that all
the time
do they yeah on their phone and stuff in
the bath yeah girls do that how are they
comfortable
they just are in it i don't i what
because
up girls are short
you need to remember girls are short but
still they're not floating
yeah i know but like it goes up
but if you have your legs out
and you shuffle all the way down you're
not on the up up bit anymore
i don't know i've just seen it i've just
all i'm saying is i've seen it and it
they seem comfortable
but yeah you would never catch me on my
front in the bath ever like a yeah just
batty just cheeks just above the water
nah buoyant
airborne family could never be no no no
no um this one's jokes paying for things
with vouchers
yeah fam the other day at work
there was a group of guys that came in
like they tried to floss or they tried
to flex they're wearing like drip per se
got a bottle of tequila ordered so much
food a couple girls joined the table
they paid with three vouchers
and then left the left what was
remaining was 30 pounds they paid that
in cash that's embarrassing with three
vouchers like that's embarrassing don't
don't bring all this yeah that's fine
that's embarrassing pay with vouchers
bro
just don't i remember yeah i'm it's so
funny yeah i can
i've always thought i would never pay
with vouchers i remember when i used to
go on dates to like pizza express
like my girlfriend at the time would
always be like oh google see if they've
got a voucher the only one i use voucher
is dominoes okay that's the only one i
use vouchers for um because i just try
and find the code and then do it yeah
they've always got a code yeah yeah but
yeah pizza express again always run like
little office and stuff like that so
we'd always go piece of express and she
was like oh try and get out to try and
get vouchers i'm not a big man no and
then i'd look for like a minute if i
can't find one like a minute she's gonna
keep looking keep looking and then she'd
be like oh when the waitress comes just
ask if they've got any offers going i
was like no foul i'll just pay for it
that's um jesus christ
yeah
um
but yeah that's embarrassing if i was
one of those girls i would be disgusted
and i think
i think the girls asked to join them
because they saw they saw the parties
they saw the fight that could
potentially pop and they saw a couple of
vouchers that he had because when they
left i didn't see those girls leave with
them
so i was like wait the girls asked if
they could join the table oh i think so
what's never happened
this is in the restaurant yeah they were
ordering food and drink and the girls
rocked up were they paying no oh okay
never mind it might they could have been
paying for them yeah in my opinion they
won't be
fair enough so yeah that's gang though
i mean it is
it is does that happen a lot
um
most more so with people that know other
people
okay yeah i was to say i can see it
happen well i can obviously see it
happen and it happens all the time with
like
if you get a table in a club mm-hmm
[ __ ] always want to follow cover it's
infuriating of course but um yeah in a
restaurant just because you could see
man flossing in a restaurant that's
weird didn't it that is weird it's
different anyway but yeah they're paired
with vitamins just embarrassing shame on
them yeah shame 100 shame on them um
velcro wallets
yeah yeah wow these look got specific
with it bro that's what i'm saying
bullet pointed bro velcro wallets baggy
boxes
then kitchen's house when there's too
much when it's too loose oh
shame bro you need to fill up the whole
yeah i haven't worn baggy boxes since i
was in like
secondary school
kitchen's house you actually said it
makes sense i'm reminding myself about
it now wow that's hilarious
these gun fingers
grabbing their crotch
gym selfies
man bags i do hear that one sometimes
posing with bottles posing with bottles
of drink in the club that you can buy
for 20 pound in asda
fair
winking i don't agree with that
men who use their tesco club card
that's a personal attack
that's a personal attack
yo
that's personal attack
i love my club card yeah
i read it and i was so sweet
oh [ __ ] so sweet shame oh that's so
hilarious shame
yo
lay off man what's wrong with the club
card
it's not the same as a voucher
that's embarrassing
all right man say let's sweet it'd be
all right whatever in it running for the
bus
understandable yeah
understandable understandable
understandable taking the bus
taking the bus i can't remember the last
time i took a bus for a bus
i can't remember the last time i took a
bus 30 year old man taking bus oh god no
come on come on man i'd rather walk
toes hairy toes
i don't think i've see ever seen hairy
toes i mean i have hair on my toes but
it's not i won't say it's hairy yeah how
can you get hairy toes
there's literally like two little
follicles that pop out they must be
looking at some next member yeah i don't
know um yeah that's it bro there's
there's loads there's like five pages of
bullet points but i'm not going for it
all right that's hilarious
oh bro the ones that stick out for me
those about that voucher in the club the
club card is painful but i disagree i
can see where they're trying to come
from but it's a little contact this
little tap allow me in it
um
and um
the nail
the knelting resonates and um
what other one the velcro wallet
the velcro wallet is hilarious to me
oh my god wow that's funny you've got to
cry you know that's funny that's just
that's it that means they're so specific
they're very specific james they were
better than the what gives me nick yeah
men clearly don't give a [ __ ]
we don't women are specific yeah yeah
anything can turn a woman off someone
just put men in there that's the first
thing i said i think what does what men
give me the in general
leave us be man
ah [ __ ]
here's what it is it's kind of painful
actually
um
wowzers okay
i don't even know where to go with that
have you got would you rather
um never have i haven't done one in ages
i don't think oh have a go would you
rather i'm sure i do actually let's have
a look see
okay
okay
this is an interesting one so you have
to put yourself in the perspective of
like a sports player
okay
um
so let's say you've been training i'd
say football yeah you've been training
all your life to be a footballer you're
a footballer would you rather
get paid 170 grand a week
to sit on the bench
never play
or 20 grand a week to be a starter
170 bags and never play never ever play
oh no if i've if i've trained all my
life through football i'm taking the 20
bags and playing
for sure for sure i'm taking it because
i feel like
even watching football now when i see
people like
marshall for example if he's if he's on
the bench and he wants to start or he's
on the bench and he's not getting subbed
on
i can see the frustration regardless of
the amount of money they're getting they
just want to play sometimes yeah that's
what they want to do yeah all they want
to do is want to play yeah whether
you're going to start at 11 or you're on
the bench to be subbed sometimes you
just you're on the um sub sometimes
you're on the bench rather than you're
part of the subs you just know you're
not getting stuff done you just know it
like um one mata for example yeah he's
on the bench quite a bit i think he's 31
32.
he's he's been he's been benching he's
he's seasonally oh his career is nearly
done with the united for sure
so even if he's on the squad on the
bench list he knows he's not playing he
knows he's not playing but you'll
probably play like a
a mid-week different cup game like a
carabao cup or an fa cup yeah yeah
probably either start or be subbed on
one of those games
he's not playing he just knows it
he just knows it donny van der beek he
got um
he originally came from ix um he's a
dutch player coming from alex to united
last year
or mid season because we have um in
football we've got two
uh
two transfer winners one in january and
one before the beginning of the next
season so i think he came last january
you think he played a couple times
and this season's done [ __ ] all right
they're not but but not not by his
choice obviously i think i just think
ollie doesn't like him
he plays so even he's on the bench
constantly and he knows every day i'm
probably not going to play
i'm probably not going to play
in my [ __ ] and these men train we can
recap bro not to play
so that's why i have 100 i'll take the
20 bags and just play if i've trained
all my life to play bro yeah
yeah i have to
yeah
i always used to think when i used to
watch football when these men are
sitting on bench with the with the coat
the massive [ __ ] coat and they sat
there like that
i'm not showing up bro i'm not showing
up especially during winter because you
have to be on the bench i'm not doing it
if i know especially if i'm injured i'm
injured promise you now i'm not showing
up
i'm not showing up bro i love my team i
do yeah it's [ __ ] freezing bro
come on man cut my salary take a few k
off me a week let me chill chill at home
let me really rest
let your boy really get some rest so i
could be back soon yeah don't make me
sit out there in the cold for what
freeze [ __ ] freeze
oh [ __ ] that's the reason i said to
myself i don't think i could ever
um i don't think i could ever be a
footballer like because when i watch
football i think it's either snowing or
like pissing down with rain i'm just not
i'm a coward when it comes to the
weather about a [ __ ] coward as soon
as i walk onto that that grass and then
my studs aren't even penetrating i'm
coming off fam i'm not doing this
because i don't want a slight tackle i
don't want anyone to tackle me i don't
want my knees to touch the grass
i don't want my knees you'll see me just
running like that as soon as someone's
curling into the ball oh stop
oh
like sterling all day
yeah i'm a coward in the weather bro bro
i'm not on it i hated it in school
rugby
when you catch the ball and you can't
even feel it because your [ __ ]
fingers are numb
i hated it yeah that was i remember
playing rugby in year seven that was the
i think that was the last time i played
rugby the last time you played rugby's
he's seven to my knowledge because i
went to rugby school
um we've had a discussion before yeah
yeah yeah i went to rugby secondary
school in year seven but i don't think i
played rugby any other year
maybe i didn't year 10 but i can't
remember but i know i played rugby in
year seven and i remember those nights
bro those cold ass after school nights
especially in winter when it goes dark
around four or five hours oh and you're
at the train you know you've got an away
game or you've got a tournament nah
brother nah brother
catching some deji
some dodgy egg ball yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] rugby you [ __ ] try and
catch and you just like clips your
fingers by mistake you don't catch it
probably just yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and it's freezing you just want to
scream you just want to scream get me
off
sub me now yeah you're just not honest
bro i remember i remember that one when
it licks your top of your fingers like
that and you're freezing your nails are
blue and it [ __ ] hurts oh yeah
you just want to kick someone in the
shin bro oh [ __ ] gun yeah i hated it i
remember and it used to be freezing cold
every time i'd score a try
i would just put the ball down
and then my my um
the ttp teacher it was a big rugby guy
and you're like oh why don't you ever do
anything like fancier like
go in some slides and i'm like it's
minus two
i'm not sliding on anything
you don't get it i used to gently just
place the ball down and walk back i hate
it out here
that's how i know i that's this is how i
know i didn't even like slide it in
summer
i didn't i wasn't involved with it
whatsoever
this was this was definitely a seven i
remember the other time i did play rugby
it was in college so i knew i played
rugby again i remember when i was in
college but back in year seven
um we were playing and we were either
playing a friendly at our school or we
were playing
like the a team versus the b team from
our school but i remember it was in our
school yeah yeah um
so
i was i can't remember the positions but
i was on the wing because i was fast
back there yeah all i used to do was run
same they did all i used to do was they
hired me to run and that was like
literally all they taught me they didn't
even teach me the rules bro they did you
said you can't fast forward you have to
pass back and i [ __ ] didn't run bro
because i was never in the scrimmage i
wasn't big enough back then i was yeah
everything's huddled same thing i was
never in this huddle thing i even
involved i was the man on the wing try
to round when i see man doing you know
when they get tackled and they used to
roll to the side and then push the ball
out and then these men would do i didn't
know what was going on i used to just
wait in the wings just waiting to catch
the ball when i got the ball oh you run
that's it
so that was my position right
so there was one time
um they did a little scrimmage thing
kick the ball on the grip yeah i got it
fam
started yeah i was running for my life
cop of mine trying to get was ah
fam got to the end line i died
obviously i knew that's what i used to
do because obviously you have to go down
with the boy
make contact with the floor yeah
i really launched and i launched the
ball
but my teacher came up to me like
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] idiot
bro what are you doing he said i'm gonna
let you have this try because that was a
fantastic run but never do that again
you bought those nfl i did the exact
same thing
i did the exact same thing in yourself
i'm not sliding on this sam and a
tournament i did the exact same thing
first ever rugby tournament had a dirty
run
made it was like bang
[ __ ] you i thought it was antonio brown
bang
and then my teacher was there like you
[ __ ] idiot bro you've wasted the
whole time the whole that's not a try
but the re
i didn't do it for the facade of
throwing it down and making it seem like
it is you just don't want to touch it i
just did the momentum i was running out
yeah the velocity i was running now no
no no no it would have taken me if i
slid yeah yeah i would have ruined my
skin but my fear was always that i would
slide and the ball would get caught
under my butt yeah and you would do like
a rolly party over there wasn't on it
because that might slide like this yeah
yeah i'm not gonna on it i'm not doing
that i'm not on it bro i'm not doing
that yeah seven as well i was a feeble
little you yeah i'm not breaking bones
like that bro yeah i remember i i didn't
even know the [ __ ] rule i still don't
know the rules of rugby this throw-in
ting everyone's lifting man up
by the ankles yeah
nah i didn't understand anything just
run me the ball and let me run that's it
that's all i was there for oh that
sounds like all i was there i can't
believe you said you did that because
it's exactly what i [ __ ] i dashed it
on the ground ah that's so funny [ __ ]
hell that's my probably my one and only
memory of playing rugby i can't remember
anything i remember getting
decked by one breath who was like he had
the body of like a 25 year old when we
were like 14. oh god he [ __ ]
developed quick his name was liam oh god
and he fam in this rugby thing he was
the god of our school because we were in
a rugby school okay so every time we go
to rugby tournaments we'll just get our
ass kicked yeah but then when he started
playing rugby
bro the teachers were gassed off him he
was so [ __ ] big he would just manage
everyone
and we win games purely because of him
yeah purely because of him and then um
yeah one time we were playing at school
in pe
and i was making a run and he came in
and just literally
banged his shoulder into my chest i hit
the floor like that i went straight back
and hit the floor like that fab knocked
all the way down me i can't imagine i
was like
[Music]
for ages and he's like you're right he
tapped me on my chest like you're right
mate
crying i was like 13 i was like
i could not breathe through that and you
know you're there and you're just like
i've never been winded like that in my
life i'm gonna [ __ ] knock you out
bro when do you speak about wyndar i
remember one time this is back where i
used to live in crystal palace at my old
old old gaff we lived in a we lived in a
gated community back then okay
we had like a small little hill it
wasn't like a it was probably about
this steep probably like a 35 degree
angle
um that just for you to get your car out
gate go out blah blah so i'd always used
to like back then i used to skateboard i
had to have roller blades and i used to
ride my bike you just bomb it down this
mini 35 degree steep hill
i remember
i was practicing my skids on my bike
yeah so the way the hill went top of the
hill my house was at the top of the hill
it goes down and you turn the gates
there but
further forward was a little an extra
dip that was that that had like a old
garage don't know why it was always
there it was an extra dip so going over
going practicing my skis to do the turn
i missed the turn
broke
but i didn't turn at all my ting flipped
my i fell over the bike oh wow landing
in that little ditch thing my stomach
went bang bang
i looked back because my neck was like
that so i was looking back at the bike
the bikes wheels were spinning yeah
couldn't breathe there was no one else
around i thought i wasn't going to stand
up again yeah
there was no one else i was broad
daylight yeah from like 3pm on a
saturday yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i've never been so winded james bro
oh being winded is the worst feeling
it's a it's a fear
because you feel like i can't catch my
breath yeah yeah and i don't know when
it's going to come yeah yeah uh i
remember there was one time i told you
that i had a a basketball hoop in my
background
i thought i broke both my wrists at the
same time
i thought i broke both my eyes at the
same time i've never been so scared fam
so painting a picture so let's say i'm
facing the basketball hoop yeah so the
way my garden went was you come out of
the house into the garden you've got
like i don't know 10 feet of
patio yes and then so if you're looking
out into my garden you look forward
you've got 10 feet of patio in front of
you and then you've got
[ __ ] i don't know 30 40 feet of
um
grass yeah
um and then if you look here my
basketball hoop was here
and to separate a flower bed so as soon
as you get under the grass on this side
there was a massive flower bed
which i think we got rid of actually so
yeah and there was a little wall
so if you're looking here you've got
patio patio um my basketball hoop but
just to the left of the basketball hoop
was like a little wall was probably like
a foot high
so
me being me was like i want to practice
my dunks
so i went onto the grass i would hold
the ball
and i would sprint jump off the one foot
thing and try and dunk it right yeah it
makes sense yeah yeah so i was doing
that doing that fam one day running
running running full pedal
went to take my step my foot slipped off
the ting
ball went flying in the air
and i landed like that arms out straight
bang on my on my hands
fan a rod onto my back and my wrist i've
never felt so stiff
and i was laying there like that feet
still on one foot still on the wall and
i was like oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god fam and i started like
twisting my wrists like crazy like
please don't be broken please i'm broken
because you know when you're waiting for
the pain to set in you're thinking these
are definitely [ __ ] broken from the
way i just landed yeah these are
definitely broken and i could feel it
getting like more and more and more and
more painful and i'm just kept right for
like 10 minutes i was just rotating my
wrists like that damn
never been so scared the next day both
of them were [ __ ] swollen to [ __ ]
luckily they weren't broken but [ __ ]
[ __ ] me that happened to me but i was
playing football um i probably said this
story on here before it's when i broke
my
left wrist my skatepad scaphoid bone in
my left wrist playing football this was
back in um college we're playing it was
just like five on five in like our in
our board in a boarding house
um i think someone went for a throw-in
and i was marking someone and i jumped
into the air to try and hit the ball
but as i landed i think my
heel missed the step so i rolled
backwards
but i landed this way and my left wrist
obviously hit the pavement to try and
stop myself from like my ass hitting the
floor
but i didn't i think the adrenaline of
the game just kept me going but i didn't
really necessarily feel a crack or
anything then and there but i think it
was when maybe i was i tried to take a
throw-in or something i felt something
and someone said that they heard
something as well when i landed but
again i defeated or hear anything but i
felt the pain about 10 minutes after i
was like [ __ ] i can't do anything about
it i went to the back then we had
matrons that people had nurses that
looked after us in the boarding house
went to her shed put ice on it blah blah
don't think it's broken don't think it's
sprayed i don't think it's fractured i
just think it's sprayed put some ice in
it i was like cool next i think it was a
friday
because i remember i didn't go to the
hospital until like sunday monday so i
put ice on it on the saturday and then i
tried to rotate like you said my wrist
was swollen james it was like an apple
it was like a [ __ ] apple jesus christ
i was like babes
this isn't this isn't just spring we
need to go somewhere yeah i can't move
it
where's the hospital now donnie said
it's been fractured yeah it's been
fractured since the initial impact oh
wow i had a cast on for three months i
remember taking it off
going back and i was like yeah you need
another three months my g i'll say no no
no that's a lie sorry i went for six
weeks
took it off and said you need another
six weeks oh yeah because i remember and
i remember i think
in between the first six weeks and the
second six weeks
we had a scheduled trip to alton towers
like the whole the whole gaff and i was
like if this cast [ __ ] me for autumn
tiles i'm going to be leaving yeah i
want to scream at everyone obviously
back then i didn't know the rules of
water i didn't know whether if you have
a cast they're not going to let you in i
don't know the rules yeah you know the
same yeah yeah yeah but obviously they
let me know i still had fun whatever but
yeah i had it for for 12 weeks bro wow
most infuriating thing because it just
itches as well yeah but one good thing
about it though it got me out of washing
dishes at home mama was like
my mom was vex after two weeks she
couldn't care less like you're washing
dishes you're washing all the dishes i
don't care i ain't doing this anymore
that's [ __ ] funny
all right let's do um yeah
all right so
what's good guys uh i just wanted to
start off by saying i love the pod i
listen to every episode blah blah blah
blah blah blah sorry dude um
all right i've gotten them out of the
[ __ ] okay so i'm 19
not a virgin but this was my first ever
like meet a girl and two days later
we're doing the ting okay
so we just finished and everything was
calm until she like started talking like
a crazy woman
talking about being together forever and
getting to know each other better and
spoil each other
after how many days
two two days
so they've met spoke for a couple of
days and then banged
[Music]
um she just told me before we did
anything about how many people have done
her wrong typical
so
she loves it she loves to project yeah
yeah so as she's saying all these crazy
things to me i'm agreeing with her and
stuff because she's talking about
chopping off my meat
and like no one has said this to me so
quickly so in my head i'm thinking this
[ __ ] is crazy rugs
now i'm home and i want to be the nice
guy and keep talking to her but i'm
scared as [ __ ] of her i really want to
lock her off am i the [ __ ] p.s she's
the one who initiated everything and she
made a move on me
no you're not an [ __ ] my g jesus
christ she's talking about loving off
your tall fam if you don't act crack i'm
gonna if you don't act right i'm robbing
off your tool you're not so they spoke
for a couple days everything was sweet
they banged and straight after when it's
cuddle time she said we're gonna be
together forever forever i want this
forever we're gonna be together forever
and if you [ __ ] me over i'm gonna cut
your dick off imagine being in the feet
position on her teeth just looking up at
her off as she's saying that post nut
you're comfortable you're relaxed you're
about to um about to snooze
bless you and she runs you all of that
she could never what is going on never
ever she's projecting some past [ __ ]
yeah bro we're not going to be together
forever
we're going to be together all day
we're not going to be together from
today
i'll tell you that for free
what do you mean
yeah yeah yeah he you need to block her
fam you used to do all sorts you need a
blocker i would ne i never really
advised like yeah that kind of action
but you have to block it but she's
acting crazy she's crazy you're talking
the most yeah you need you need to make
sure if she knows where you live it's
long but as long as she doesn't know
where you live you need to just send her
a message about look
you're on some crazy thing and don't
this is not me doing you dirty like you
told ever you said everyone else does
your day
i'm just worried for my safety yeah you
moved to me we united and now you're
saying we're going to be together
forever like i'm not about it i'm just
i'm just not about it it's just it's
just this red flag
good luck but she knows where he lives
by the way yeah she's 100
if you're telling me i'm like but i'm
going to love her for your dick she
already knows where you live she already
knows where you live she's cracked she's
been practicing this
[ __ ] sorry sorry g i think you obviously
you're not the [ __ ] for trying to
like lock her off or whatever but bro
she's cracked
like everyone would agree that's crazy
talk yeah it's crazy talk sorry bro
sorry bro good luck with that yeah man
let us know how that goes yeah let us
know if you still got your meat he sent
this in a while ago so i want to know if
he's even still alive hopefully you are
due
i hope you are because
because that's tough that is tough
anyway guys happy monday um we'll see
you on thursday over at patreon you know
the vibes uh make sure you get your
tickets for the festival link in the
description and
yeah man have a great day
love love
[Music]